400 de postes menacés chez nokia lannion
c'est un coup dur pour le secteur des
télécommunications en bretagne région en
pointe dans le domaine dans les années
60 le déploiement de ce secteur a donné
un nouvel élan économique à lannion et
ses environs à l'avant garde
il y a le centre national d'études des
télécommunications où la téléphonie
moderne a été la bourse il ya aussi des
transmissions par satellite qui ont
permis le déploiement de la télévision
grâce aura d'homme à pleumeur bodou
le président de gaulle l'inaugurant 1962
vive la science française
vive la bretagne et vive la france ces
infrastructures ont pris place à lannion
grâce à pierre marzin grands ingénieurs
breton à paris quand il a fallu
délocaliser son activité il a choisi sa
terre natale en faisant une sorte de
silicon valley je pense que le plus de
choses
les centraliser dans l'ombre désert où
on pouvait avoir la chance d'essayer de
faire d'adp et gère quelque chose de
fantastique comme les américains par
exemple vous font une ville d'angers
légère côté industrie il y à la société
lannionnaise d'électricité elle est
absorbée par alcatel en 1977 et
représente près de 2000 emplois lannion
le secteur se porte bien jusque dans les
années 80 début d'un enchaînement de
plans sociaux en 1984 d'abord dans un
contexte de rigueur après le deuxième
choc pétrolier 190 emplois supprimés
d'autres s'en suivent en 1996 1998 et
celui de 2006 à la faveur de la fusion
d'alcatel lucent deux géants des
télécommunications
ça va donner des doublons
les pros des lignes de produits qui
visent les mêmes marchés donc on
s'inquiète à ce sujet là en 2007 encore
12000 postes sont supprimés dans le
monde dont 1500 en france le pôle de
recherche et développement n'y échappe
pas le président de la région bretagne
jean-yves le drian défense at outil de
compétitivité
nous avons en bretagne une qualité de
recherche et une compétence scientifique
et technique dans ce domaine qui est
reconnu de tous
on ne comprend pas pourquoi on s'attaque
à ses fleurons de notre industrie
régionale en 2015 alors que nokia est
sur le point de mettre la main sur
alcatel lucent les nouvelles craintes de
la part du personnel
le ministre de l'économie emmanuel
macron obtient des garanties de
l'entreprise et annonce de nouveaux
projets pour lannion un nouveau bell
labs sera ouvert ici à lannion pour
développer les activités en particulier
dans la 5g la cybersécurité au
l'internet
pour autant l'activité n'est pas épargné
un plan social en 2017 un nouveau
aujourd'hui et il ne devrait rester que
370 salariés chez nokia à lannion
[Musique]